what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports you know there's
nothing quite like a grand final
the crowd is intense there's everything
to play for and victory is so close you
can just about taste it whether it's the
final match in an incredible lower
bracket run or another shot at the
coveted Aegis grand finals have given us
some of the most memorable dota 2
matches of all time so sit back hit that
subscribe button and get ready as we
count down the top 10 most memorable
dota 2 grand finals coming in at number
10 is team secret vs. Team Liquid at the
Shanghai major the Shanghai major was
known for many things poor production
participants playing without proper
equipment and of course the public
firing of James too good harding but
that shouldn't detract from the exciting
dota that was played team secret may
have knocked Team Liquid out in the
upper bracket but liquid defeated
reigning TI winners evil geniuses in the
loser's bracket finals to give them
another shot at team secret in the grand
finals I'm actually really surprised I
think going in I would have picked
neither team to even make tough four
[Music]
they had a second line company but a
turn levees just dripping liquid apart
they're gonna try and blow them up too
quick Ravi they'll be able to do
somebody told Nikki and now the static
storm it disrupts everything they love
being surrounded by team secret there's
no getting up say you're gonna go I try
and get the tomb that does God go on to
get off the Cronus ear but it's still a
turtle let me go straight from a toughie
man the TV's out for Fatih he knows this
by cannot be one with rival or Thompson
this could be liquid all dying another
shackleshot we ha he's shown it big in
the Bolger went down in their face but
now we've us going to be able to make
sure it's a total wipe and there it is
congratulations team secret take Game
four in one of the most dominant
fashions we've seen in the grand finals
team secret defeated liquid 3-1 marking
the first time that this super team won
a valve event what a game that was I
think it is only fitting to see team
secret and with such a dominant game as
they did surely your Shanghai made their
Champions
coming in at number nine is Alliance
versus infernity a trade call EMS summer
cup for in the summer of 2013 Alliance
were one of the most dominant teams in
dota 2 down and it looks like the
Alliance is gonna roll over DK GG is
cold and Alliance that's three games
they take they will walk away with first
place prize and they've played a
fantastic season they are in my opinion
the best team in the world
which is why it was no surprise that the
Swedish team faced little resistance on
their path to the smaller tournaments
grand final but things really got
interesting when caster Toby one issued
them a challenge the challenge which was
sent to Alliance by myself as joking ish
and then they asked he said okay who's
actually to get it ranked in ten minutes
well the challenge was issued as a joke
support player okay accepted it and the
team drafted a heavy push pause I mean
already from the start looking at fury
unless right we know it's gonna be
something of a push but taking racks in
ten minutes then yeah this is probably a
type of lineup you on Alliance not only
managed to take a lane of racks but beat
infernity in
eight minutes and 43 seconds infernity
would get their revenge in Game two but
Alliance ultimately won the series
coming in at number eight is Mineski
beating LGD gaming at the dota 2 Asia
Championship 2018 while Southeast Asia
has always been seen as a strong region
this tournament saw them win their first
dota 2 major and they did it by taking
on some of DotA's best teams see drops
down the toolbox not just the hammer and
kicks PG gaming down to the bottom
bracket bull dead without by Mike LGD
Technica's gg gg they can't fight back
off to that one the grand final saw
mineski go face to face with one of
China's best LGD gaming the two teams
went back and forth in a series that
went all five games in the end
mineski were the ones left standing
the two of them seconds without my mic
available mineski ready to go all in
they just can't slow this down LGD
Mineski Asian legends they absolutely
are mushi rip through Ltd the edge you
won't fall
I mean Mineski this team you will know
them you'll love them you're 2018 DAC
major champions coming in at number 7 is
OG vs team secret at the frankfurt major
despite a poor showing in the group
stage oh gee put together a historic run
that saw them take the lower bracket by
storm blitz it has been a miraculous run
some might say for OG they have taken
down fnatic mineski virtus pro c deck
and a home to get here they are 9 and 2
in their last 11 games the green dream
is strong but the boys in blue they
stand in opposition
he's gonna try to lock up now the echo
though
he's down
no by backgrounder universe could be
next GG
[Applause]
they send the boys of blue packing and
they have a date with team secret and
the best-of-five Frankfurt major grand
finals
this is the most unlikely lower bracket
run in the history of dota 2 in the
first-ever dota 2 major grand final oh
gee would come face to face with the
team they had some personal beef with
team secret earlier in the year both fly
and no tail left secret a team that they
had helped found team secret was the
final obstacle standing in the way of
the greatest lower bracket run in dota 2
history you can take a little bit the
time in chopping appoint three man-crush
Kody would go on to beat team secret 3-1
in the series defeating their rivals and
putting together a tournament run that
would be remembered for years to come
Thank You Jerome the dream runner
achieving what no other team has done
and no other team will probably achieve
for a very long time coming in at number
six
we've got Alliance vs. LGD at the g1
Champions League season five at the time
China was widely regarded as the most
dominant region in dota 2 but Alliance
were making waves in the EU seen and
many dota 2 fans wanted to see them take
on the world's best teams this is even
better than I in my opinion because you
have aligns the foreigner the weaker
he was coming from this unknown country
to these Chinese guys to China and they
are just beating up on everybody as the
main tournament began Alliance and
liquid were tapped as the West's only
representatives TL put up a poor showing
in the group stage but Alliance more
than made up for it going five-o in
their group stage and landing an
automatic spot in the grand finals
they're the future TI winners were set
to go head-to-head with one of Asia's
most powerful dota 2 teams LGD gaming
but that didn't faze Alliance it's just
it's all ending in a flurry here for LGD
there's no art thief it's boy now for 40
seconds entangle on shall we dip in some
s Forks load up he smells blood in the
water so does his squad the Alliance the
Swedes they're gonna take Game one Gigi
from LGD they catch on can't wait can
they bring them down the time Lotus P is
gonna pop the beat baby waited a second
or two to do it I love that decision oh
I'm playing a crit and probably a kill s
for diving LGD and the shadow of their
foul GG from Xiao Wei the Alliance are
your g1 league season 5 champions coming
in at number 5 is oh gee vs. virtus pro
at the kiev major the best of 5 final
was a back and forth affair but the
fifth game was the one that showed the
world y OG could arguably be considered
a dynasty final predictions said we got
rid Game five
could we curse one can you just beat
can't I'm God's game 5 of a major I'm
just gonna go with what my gut says and
that's that bogeys ever made three times
major champions for a reason an
aggressive draft from VP cut og by
surprise they pick an enchantress yes
wow that's boozy Oh in basic the
alchemists do Wow and the European team
played most of the first half on their
heels that impetus he doesn't have the
range but anna is done
kkuk option they need the vision flight
37 Gurgaon as well they destroy ergy on
the bottom Lane bring it the Templar one
is just doing his work he sublime
through this he wants one more hit on
their tail solo Ashley gets the kill
they caused the fatal boats they admit
by the engines had full heroes guard
down for G with their backs against the
wall
oh gee brought the fight to VP no septa
the keeping already on the five and the
big word
they're holding in there but the damage
you'll drop the hammer for the bash
again and still doing this work their
tail this timbersaw he's the man doing
the damage until Anna throws a lockdown
you actually have the fight going the
way of her G acquittal to push away no
one needs to keep the damage going he
doesn't have the Eclipse too many are
falling right now the photos burnwell
back in the Viper the whole silver and
small
he's called them three down this can be
the enchilada right now and here they
come stampede jump ball down low the
rocks will drop I just aren't half the
damage to her G time don't return major
winners here at camp at number four
we've got Oh G versus ad finem
at the Boston major during the
qualifiers ad finem managed to sweep
both team secret and Team Liquid defying
pretty much everyone's expectations
after making it through the group stage
look like ad finem couldn't be stopped
first new villain bounced back by the
chunk AP comes forward does manage gets
by a spotter up under doesn't matter
they are so ineffective they can't stop
ad finem second lfy
arrow blocked in maybe next time jump or
they can I chop down the trees I throw
this down
then digital chaos here banner begins
ticking tightening around saga one step
ahead Terrigal appliances
I start
[Applause]
and then the final boss oh gee but while
oh gee we're favourites heading into the
tournament the Greek squad had heart
soul and a chant that took over the
venue
well Oh G had their number most of the
game it was maybe next times courageous
play that took the hearts of dota fans
everywhere
[Applause]
the team may not have won the series or
the major but ad finem stood tall in the
face of a dota 2 giant they managed to
draw blood and capture the hearts of
dota 2 fans everywhere it's like it was
scripted it was it's like it was been
I've never seen you lose it like that
what about you guys
Alex did you guys lose it as far as we
did seriously say hi I am blown away
what a absolute [ __ ] treat taking the
number 3 spot
we've got newbie vs. Team Liquid at TI 7
imagine playing on all the right teams
but at the wrong time this was the
reality for kuroky he would always play
on top tier teams but could never
capture the ever elusive Aegis at TI 7
Team Liquid had to fight their way
through the dreaded lower bracket just
to make it to the finals controllable
they can
another tool one mid once down it's all
I used up as well similar cases in
resolution moving in but Gigi good luck
next is caught by Empire piece sonic
wave hey we'll be back up in a second
50g ball played team liquid will
eliminate them from the International
he's got ldd on the ropes now
and liquid surgeon they want this our
chichi
[Applause]
that bee gave me he's down to half can
actually cure
[Applause]
it took kuroky four years before he
returned to an international grand final
and all that was standing in his way was
one of China's top teams newbie this
time he would not let the ages slip away
don't forget our motto don't give up
don't give a [ __ ] the less [ __ ] we give
the better we will play I waited four
[ __ ] years for this day this time
we're gonna rewrite yes this could be
the final game of tea.i vs newbee are
down low and to teamliquid has made an
extraordinary run winning six
consecutive series to get here
go get the funding from the
but take everything from food to the
[Applause]
Hiroki would finally become a TI
champion
[Applause]
taking the runner-up spot on this list
is C Dec vs evil geniuses at ti5 a
series that will forever be remembered
for one single play a play that could
only happen if all the pieces were in
the right place a play that will go down
in history as B $6,000,000
echo slam there is no hook shot there
altogether PPT here comes the ice planet
[Applause]
it was one of the most incredible plays
in dota 2 history and while the series
had its fair share of memorable moments
this one took the cake we were in
control of the game but they just picked
off Samara and they were trying to take
Roche and they all walked into the pit
we didn't have vision of them at the
time but then I told PPE to throw in a
nice vortex and threw it in there and I
saw a couple of them so I just assumed
they'd all be in there and I just made a
flying leap of faith and then they okay
they're all in there and they all died
my first reaction after the echo slam I
just yelled I don't even know what's
talking about in my mouth but it was
pretty loud it was the play that made eg
ti champions a play that made eg six
million dollars richer finishing off our
list at number one is Navi vs. Alliance
at ti3 as the only ti final that needed
all five games to crown of Viktor the
nearly three million dollar prize pool
was essentially left to a best of 1o
comes down to this one more game two
million dollars on the table winner
first place at the international the
agent and the prestige of being the best
dota 2 team in the world when the final
game began both teams were considered
equal and victory for either was about
as certain as a coin toss Alliance
trailed most of the game and Navi
appeared to have their number then s4
did something that amazed everyone GP
quick right now a scores gonna try to
cancel as many as possible he'll cancel
three
but Nick's gonna try to keep people's
gonna defend against everybody meanwhile
load up and working on the mainly rocks
on the bottom of Rihanna rip funny
you're getting stuck or he's gonna get
back out for the racks in huge trouble
they will defend dream coil after dream
coil after dream coil s4 managed to
completely halt na vi's momento they
can't roch they don't have enough damage
they don't have enough ep he's he
canceled the beat copy clop he's not
gonna be back in the face he's got BK me
but no boots of travel now take over the
throne it could be game
[Music]
this would go down in the minds of dota
2 fans everywhere as one of the greatest
games ever played
the first-ever international for the
swings all right guys that's our list
now if your favorite dota 2 grand final
was not on it consider writing an angry
incoherent 500 word rant in the comment
section below thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button